moi je suis en admirateur
alors Françoise Hardy vous êtes ici ce
soir pour un nouvel album qui s'appelle
parenthèse quand disent les astres ça va
être un succès
très bien et il est très bien ce dis
c'est 12 du haut donc alors il y a des
duos avec Alain Delon Jacques Dutronc
Julio Iglesias ben Christopher Alain
Souchon Rodolph burger Henri Salvador
Arthur H Moran Benjamin Biolay Hélène
Grimaud
alors Françoise c'est un carton et c'est
mérité parce qu'il y a quelques pépites
dans ce disque moi j'adore par exemple
partir quand même avec Julio Iglesias il
y a aussi 7 ans voilà ça y est je perds
je perds mon stérilet comme
[Rires]
alors il y a aussi cet enfant que je
t'avais fait de Higelin et Brigitte
Fontaine avec Rodolph burger il y a que
reste-t-il de nos amours avec Bashung et
là but note list la pépite My Beautiful
Damon avec Ben Christopher
cette chanson c'est vrai que sur chaque
album on a en général une préférence
pour une deux trois chansons et ça c'est
pour moi un des enregistrements les plus
beaux auxquels j'aurais eu la chance de
participer donc c'est dû à la qualité de
la chanson qui a été composée créée il y
a quelques années par Ben Christopher un
jeune artiste britannique et c'est dû
aussi à la qualité de la réalisation qui
est vraiment exceptionnelle et qui a été
faite par
Eric Benzi voilà Françoise Hardy ça
s'appelle parenthèse et c'est chez
Virgin voilà
le plus dur à convaincre ça a été
Salvador non le plus dur à convaincre
Salvador pas du tout pas du tout
[Rires]
ah il est en pleine forme il va avoir 90
ans l'année prochaine non non
vous a autorisé à le tutoyer mais à la
troisième personne
non je me suis retrouvé dans une
situation surréaliste ou il m'avait
demandé de rester à côté de lui pendant
l'enregistrement pour lui tapoter sur
l'épaule chaque fois que c'était à lui
de parler parce qu'en fait on ne chante
pas ensemble
on ne chante pas ensemble on dit un
texte qui est très spécial très très
spécial et du tronc comment ça va alors
bah ça va mieux depuis ce duo parce que
il a
[Rires]
une énorme d'avoir une femme comme
Françoise
un admirateur
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu